it's time for screen junkies bubi fights
oh I didn't see you there hi welcome to
movie fights live what is happening
we're not live today we're pre-recorded
so you know what there's some info let's
deal with that would be remiss if I
didn't give a shout-out to Owl Nation
who do where miles at where is my owl I
do not have Percival with me today and I
feel naked as I was gonna say j-bird but
naked as an owl let's this is a very
special movie fights because we are
delving into we're swinging right into
the spider-verse an honor of the
brand-new movie into the spider-verse
and we're real excited about that and we
got some mega Spidey heads my spidey
senses are tingling with all the spider
knowledge at this table first up from
Collider heroes our good pal the master
of the speed round coy Chandra I'm so
ready for this movie fights not live
live deal with that info as you will
next up you know from SJ to you and the
nerd goat podcast Edie Grier is here hey
guys I'm back that keeps spinning the
chamber and I keep sitting in the chair
in the POW you know that's how I feel
sometimes little deep cut Vietnam movie
reference for you there and always good
to have you my friend here we're not
live today and last but not least you
can check her out over on DC daily on
the DC Universe app our good pal mega
nerd Markie McCarty
yeah now I'm glad to be here alive you
know it's all so good yeah so we're not
live
oh yes yes always a good thing and I
like your uh your Spidey hoodie you got
going on there I guess things like
low-key nerd oh and real quick I got to
point out my men clays and ro is wearing
this
Spidey t-shirt which is a drawing by
Stan Lee autographed by Stan Lee right
there
very limited edition t-shirt yeah I love
this thing because it's it's staying at
his core it shows that spider-man can be
anyone because it's literally this
iconic image is all you need to be
Spidey so it's its universality about it
yep so sick thanks for being here thanks
for wearing that shirt
and today's fights are going to be
decided by myself
and Billy and Danielle do we have a cool
sick nickname for you too I don't think
we do like Dan bill sounds weird yeah Oh
rad biz business
Billy biz you are going to be holding
down the fact-checkers cherry out here
Jay jonah Jameson today I'm keeping it
keeping it 100 right here instead of
Billy basil beat Billy bugle today right
on he needs those pictures you are
usually our social media chairwoman but
today you're gonna be chiming in with
your own thoughts and opinions on the
arguments Danielle Radford yeah normally
I do the voice of the people but today I
am going to be the voice of myself which
is always terrifying but please still
she you know you guys are so great on
the movie fights live hashtag
sharing your answer sharing your own
opinions please do continue to do that
because we do check those and we
interact as much as we can and you have
some fantastic answers to some of these
questions so please can you need to do
so while I flop sweat oh come on now all
right so yeah please still send us your
dank memes as you're watching movie
fights not live today hashtag movie
fights live though so just to remind
okay so it's the best of a best-of-seven
game first person to have four points
wins top two scores after the first
three rounds move on to the speed round
and the speed round is anybody's game
you can be down three oh and make a
furious comeback and take the whole
thing in the speed round y'all ready for
this
drop that I guess package
[Music]
Thank You Thor I feel like I'm one of
the only people that does not scene into
the spider-verse yet oh I know yeah I am
it's well worth the price of admission
no matter what so oh man I can't wait
but make your we gotta man movie and
that's saying a lot
Wow damn it goes there all right well
she with it
everything here is Spidey themed and I'm
excited this is like my my warm-up to
get for the movie which I'm going to see
as soon as humanly possible uh what is
this question number one what is the
best performance from any actor or
actress in any spider-man or Spider
related movie Wow best performance any
actor actress and any Spider Man or
spider related movie and we are going to
start with koi so it is a bold choice I
did a modern spider-man I did a
character that is very important to
spider-man
I chose Tom Holland as spider-man
because this was a spider-man that was
earnest that was heartfelt that was
funny that embody all of the things that
makes spider-man who he is and that was
so instantly a piece of the lore that
within five minutes you felt everything
you needed to for spider-man him walking
into the DVD player that instant you saw
him there was something about the
charisma of Tom Hall and they were like
oh that spider-man we didn't need an
origin story we didn't need to watch
Uncle Ben die we didn't need to have all
of the tropes because Tom Holland
embodied spider-man so much that we
already identified him and that's really
impressive considering people loved
Tobey Maguire spider-man people liked
Andrew Garfield spider-man and then Tom
Holland comes to play and instantly that
is all that matters you've got a new
spider-man and it was a beautiful thing
to see so many kids get to see a hero
their age fully embodying what they saw
as a hero and what was most important to
me about that was every time there was a
comic reference you can see the light in
his eyes like you out of Andrew Garfield
but he could tell he was a spider-man
fan but also the earnestness that you
had with Tobey Maguire so it was almost
like a greatest hits and one actor and
the moment that he lifts the rubble over
his head that references the spider-man
33 cover in spider-man homecoming when
he sees the reflection of the mask in
his face that to me was the single
it's a gif of seeing a boy become a
spider-man and that is the performance
of a lifetime especially with how much
we have invested in the character so to
me there is nothing quite like the
performance that Tom Holland gives in
the spider-man franchise all right a boy
becomes spider-man Edie well you know me
as I scraped my nails down the
chalkboard with the shark you know you
all know me I was making hard on myself
I don't take the easy choice like the
the lead of the movie I tend to go to
the performances that make the movie
work and as we're gonna stay on
homecoming he's saying Tom Holland from
homecoming if that's my understanding I
am saying Michael Keaton as the vulture
from homecoming imaginal world if you
will wear some old bum plays the vulture
where he's like he is in the comic books
where he's not menacing where he doesn't
have this super fresh Top Gun get up on
look at this guy this guy's Tom Skerritt
and and and gun this guy's amazing
kidneys and he still got the vulture
stuff puck now whoever did this custom
design is amazing the roof Carter asked
and how good they are and all I'm saying
is his performance grounds that film you
have to believe that a dude who can
throw Volkswagens is scared of some dumb
old man and you do you believe it in
that scene in the car where he's
intimidating him you believe it when
when he first shows up at the vultures
door and sees who this guy is this guy
intimidates a superhero with steely
glances and and just the the the weight
of experience and time and I do believe
that that performance with all the stuff
we know about Michael Keaton with all
the different interpolations of the
superhero aesthetic that he's gone
through from being Batman to be in
Birdman to being yet another reflection
of the superhero aesthetic being a super
villain here it's an amazing performance
it really makes this movie work if he
isn't if that performance is not there
he's just fighting a dumb old man with
gliders on his back but because it's
Michael Keaton the movie is great boom
ed Grier Michael Keaton Marc came
McCarty okay so I didn't go for the
latest
no spider-man movie that's been out I
went with spider-man to Alfred Molina as
dr. Otto Octavius
now with this performance and I'm gonna
get into specifics with it not just set
design with Alfred Molina with what he
brought to this role you felt the
transition that went from being otto
into being Doc Ock you felt the love
that he had for Rosie like he portrays
this in every which way and in
particular the scene was like a no no no
I'm not a criminal the one where the
inhibitor chip has been destroyed
where Alfred Molina is standing at the
side of the dock his work is destroyed
Rosie is dead and he is going through
this crisis and you see this transition
where it goes from being Peter's friend
auto dock into Doc Ock and the thing of
it is the thing that really gets me
about Alfred Molina is performance in
this and why I consider it to be the
best out of the spider-man movies and in
people it's because when you look at the
graphics now with it with a CGI you it's
a it looks a little bit hammy to see the
CGI with the with tentacles but it's
because of Alfred Molina spur formance
you completely believe it you believe
that these things these alien AI things
are penetrating his mind they're they're
warping him and Alfred pulls this mess
off like I don't even know it is a
master work in a superhero movie it's
like it's more than we even deserved at
that point so yeah hands down Alfred
Molina brought it home all right more
than we deserved fight it out you guys
so I feel like I love both these
performances just like to be very honest
I don't want to insult either one of
them but it is a movie fight I I feel
like there is something to Michael
Keaton's resurgence where he played a
very OneNote thing over and over again
his performance in Birdman versus
performance and Founder versus
performance and spotlight all were kind
of a curmudgeonly old man and yes that
is the vulture but at no point did I
feel like he could have done that
without Tom Holland if the if he'd if he
played the writing a little better it
would have been a more of a kingpin
versus daredevil thing where there were
two leads he was written to care
that was literally a guy scavenging that
was the underdog that was your
through-line
and he still felt like a villain and at
no point did I buy him in the suit soon
as the suit went on the CGI came to play
and I didn't believe that was him in the
suit whereas Tom Holland is an actual
Acrobat the word performance is in this
question he performed his stunts he
performed backflips and no point did I
buy that Keaton was in the soup but I
knew that Tom Holland is in the suit and
I feel like with the character of Doc
Ock he had to live up to the expectation
of being a mustache twirling villain and
did it very well
but Tom Holland had to live up to the
expectation of being spider-man there is
a one notice to a villain that is he has
to do those x y&z where a spider-man had
to be spider-man he had to be funny he
had to be heartfelt his relationship
without May there were so many more
dynamics and relationships and it was so
much more to do with Tom Holland that it
stands the test of time more than I
think that Doc Ock would think it's a
little bit disingenuous to call Michael
Keaton's performance to be like a
OneNote villain just you know a little
bit and you know for for Tom Hollis
performance yes he is a he's a really
great spider-man he is but with what you
were talking the things that you
described with it you were giving me set
dressing like oh oh he's with the DVD
player and it's like yeah I remember
that and that's something that Peter
Parker would do but it's like I don't
consider that to be part of an amazing
performance I don't consider that
specific enough to make it you know top
what Michael Keaton and some donuts and
some of those endearing things that
you're saying about spider-man when
you're opening thing are from civil war
I'd like to I'd like to make that
distinction real quick because because
the Russo brothers directing Tom Harlan
in that movie in homecoming which is
what you're citing is the super great
performance he's building on something
that's already previously been done with
other directors so it's like it's almost
like he's coming into it
whereas Michael Keaton and Alfred Molina
both had to come in fresh with new
performances not based on anything else
yeah and then keeping in mind that they
had they had you know comic book
villains that they had to flesh out with
their own performances it's because like
think about it Doc Ock before seeing him
in spider-man 2 where did we see him we
saw him in what the cartoons were just
like on Doc Ock you know
damn hostess cakes I'm fill out this doc
oxy they drop me really round exactly so
then when you see Alfred Molina and then
plus oh my god they got Alfred Molina
for that I mean keeping in mind where he
was and his career then for him to be
like it the the spider-man movies and
the Marvel movies weren't what they are
now where we have Angela Bassett now you
know and in so Washington probably soon
who knows um but like back then it's
like that that was a little bit of a
leap for him you know for Sam Raimi to
be able to get Alfred frickin Molina I
do believe that that was that was very
brave of them at not not brave or
prescient or whatever whatever you wanna
call it like that exactly and so what I
would say is also just I don't want to
disrespect our Molina's performance I do
believe when you compare it to some of
these other ones it can go into a little
ham territory a little spider-ham
territory III just I just feel like
there is a ham eNOS to my mind is being
controlled by these things there's an
inherent happiness that he fights
bravely against okay he fights bravely
against it but I don't know that he wins
that war totally whereas III if he leave
her acquiesce to the point of Michael
Keaton and the CGI suit like we know
that he's not in there however the power
of it is he's pow he's almost more
powerful without the damn suit on when
he's just sitting in the car with a
booth with a young girl's boyfriend
who's a superhero but he's not a
superhero in that moment he's just a
young boy but the vulture is Adrian
Toomes though I don't think just being
well Adrian Toomes is being the vulture
because a bunch of dumb rich
superheroes brought the city down on
everybody's head and now he's got to
clean it up but no now the rich people
get to clean it up too
so the rich people get to destroy
everything the rich people get to make
all the money off of building everything
back up and me and my crew get screwed
no way Jose I'm gonna take these silver
things these purple Jazz's I don't know
they work and me and my home he's gonna
make some dam break guys we don't cut
bigots apart cuz dammit we got we got to
do this man
and he he acts that he acts the role of
the dad who has a bunch of narrative
well kids that he has to has the
Wrangell and he's responsible for and I
think that's a huge part of performing
and a huge part of acting alright let's
move to their final thoughts koi start
us off I feel like everything user
subscribes a testament to the writers
not to the actor yes he had a great
script yes he was given all these great
choices yes he was given this underdog
character and they made the vulture very
interesting because the writing was very
good as the vulture but I also agree
with you that I do think that Sam
Raimi's Hawk was a lot more ham-fisted a
lot more cheesy than people remember and
I do think that it was a script he was
given that he did fight against very
valiantly but I don't think it was as
believable as Tom Holland that had the
uphill battle of defending a character
that already had so many reboots that
already had such a negative there's a
reason this IP is so strong right now
there's the reason the video game that
came out there's a reason the
spider-verse coming out and it's because
of Tom Holland Tom Hollands performance
bringing it back because the spider-man
homecoming is people trusting in this
new version of spider-man and it's the
only time we've ever had a spider-man
that was actually young Tom Holland felt
16 we were able to see through the eyes
of Tom Holland we got a John Hughes
spider-man in a large part because of
the performance of Tom Holland and that
was something we'd never had before
after five movies so to me Tom Holland
is not only the best performance out of
these but it was the most fulfilling for
the fans all right thank you coin Edie
well I think one of the main reasons why
Tom Holland will be able to be
spider-man four two three four hopefully
five six more movies is because of the
strength of villains you see these other
this other universe folded because
they're villains were too weak so in
that respect Michael Keaton is is is a
villain that I do believe sets up the
entire spider-verse
actually because as I stated he said
he's the one who sets up this world
where there's things that are too small
for the Avengers and too big for cops
and that spider-man's whole ouvre
Michael Keaton's performance and the
vulture as a character established
spider-man's over for movies to come
establishing that that playing field
that he that he's on and at the end when
the vulture says that he shows either
steely resolve and not stitching on
spider-man and telling people who he is
or he shows that he's got
honor either way you know times in
either way that's a great villain turn
and it's it's just a masterful
performance that I really think sells
that movie Civil War sold us a great
spider-man
but in homecoming the thing that sells
us a new spider-verse a spider universe
as it were is the vultures performance
and Michael Keaton supports our vulture
performance thank you okay so with Tom
Hollands spider-man if you had said
Civil War spider-man you go to have me
on board with like you know amazing
performance anything spider related for
with homecoming and I agree with Ed with
this heroes are defined by their
villains and in particular why Doc Ock
is the best performance out of
spider-man properties spider related
properties is because yes not only did
he have to deal with the CGI and
technology at the time he powered
through that he didn't have a massive
hide behind he literally became auto
into Doc Ock and it was just a series it
was just goggles along with that yes I
do agree though coy with what you said
Michael Keaton he's a great Adrian
Toomes he's not necessarily a good
vulture it is it is a it's a misconnect
it's just it's not quite there by but
with Alfred Molina being who Alfred
Molina is and like where he was with
that and it makes spider-man 2 so
incredibly rewatchable
it's absolutely amazing and that is
because that villain helps define Tobey
Maguire as spider-man our villains
define us and Alfred Molina defined
spider-man to time okay who will take
this round three strong arguments Billy
yeah I mean this is opinion base but
just to give a little bit of context
here how these performances stacked up
accolades wise Tom Holland won the Teen
Choice Awards for choice movie actor and
that is for the award
there is no greater honor didn't I think
about Saturn Award for Best Performance
sorry we were all that starred Tasha
what what came after the company was
also nominated for a Saturn Award for
Best Performance that Michael Keaton was
nominated also for Best Supporting Actor
at the Saturn Awards that was his only
accolade from that Alfred Molina has a
laundry list for spider-man two
nominated for British Supporting Actor
the year from the London Critics Society
he was nominated for MTV's Best Villain
that year and he I'll skip ahead a lot
of nominations for Best Villain from
certain things and then he won
outstanding performance by an actor in
visual effects by the visual effects
society Awards also coy is a hundred
percent right most of the Spider Men
before Andrew Garfield to have Maguire
all CGI creations Tom Holland was the
first where he could actually do the
flips and they mo kept Tom Hollands
actual moves Wow all right good
so yeah three three great arguments here
and it makes it very difficult but yeah
Marky III I love Alfred Molina and his
performance but I do feel like certain
elements of that movie have not stood up
over the test of time and like certain
like just chewing of the scenery and
effects wise yeah yeah is it a little
too over the top at this point it's
raised a couple of questions even though
I still love it has it aged to be like a
fine wine coy I feel like we got dinged
a little bit on yeah the the homecoming
versus a Civil War like which which
performance what was the one that
galvanized just that spider-man for us
and and you just hit some stuff that
really resonated with me like that scene
from the car and the intensity of Keaton
that gravitas that he brought to that
role I don't know that really spoke to
me so I'm going
with Edie on this one Danielle um so
they are I'm consulting my notes you
guess I'm in there so all of you had
great points and managed to ding all of
you with things it was great watching
and so for me it was really who managed
to ding everyone the worst because all
of the arguments I thought were
presented were great I do have to say
it's so it's such semantics with the
civil war versus homecoming thing it's a
fantastic point that that is a great
performance but it's building off of his
other previously great performance in
civil war which was why I couldn't do
coy which made me very very sad because
I do love the Tom Holland and I also I
you know as much as I appreciate Keaton
being great and doing great work I felt
like that argument really got knocked
down with the not being able to be the
vulture and you have to be able to do
everything you can save it out for
marillion Molina's performance is too
hammy but he was able to convincingly be
both sides of Octavio I said that room
as according to as according to Marquis
as arguments so I've got to go with Mark
eeeh boom okay one for add one from
archaea really this yeah look koi I
think you did I think you did a great
job I think you kept referencing a
couple moments and for me it just wasn't
quite enough but it's still look it
could have been anybody's game so for me
it came down to ed and Mark eeeh and I
thought you had some great stuff I think
bringing up that car scene was awesome
but for me mark Kia was the one that
said look he plays almost two characters
in this movie he convincingly gets you
to believe that he's Parker's mentor and
also the villain within the same movie
pretty convincingly so for me my vote
goes to Marky Mark II you take the point
all right worth noting these are my
three I had Tom Hall
but yeah three three strong characters
that was good on you guys
alright so mark eeeh you are ahead one
to nil to nil Edie and coy looking to
get on the board question number two
excluding anyone that is already in
spider-man into the spider verse what
comic books spider-verse character
should have their own animated feature
next excluding anyone in in the spider
verse comic book character from the
spider verse should have their animated
feature next
Edie gonna start with you okay now I
picked a character who is intrinsic to
the spider verse situation in the comic
books but obviously was not featured in
the motion picture this character is
Otto Octavius the superior spider-man I
do believe that that is right
much much in the same way that the
spider verse concept if you shear a lot
of things out of it and just keep it
real lean and mean you can make a movie
out of the spider verse situation which
is very much more complicated in the
comic books than it is even in the movie
they she are a lot of things off of it
put those put it put it together I think
you could do something like that with
the arc of superior spider-man which for
those who don't know is when octo
Octavius figures out a way to put his
consciousness in Peter Parker's body and
during the period where he is inside
Peter Parker's body he just kills the
game he kills the game he becomes a
millionaire he starts a giant tech
company he gets like a hundred and fifty
percent better at stopping crime by
using technology he basically shows you
the immense potential of Peter Parker
the Peter Parker can't even realize and
I think a movie where we started with
spider-man just sort of being like ah
man I'm sad I'm a bum I'm saving
people's lives but I'm hella bummy and
then I don't AVS gets the drop on him
and and gets inside his body and it has
this freewheeling time and towards the
end spider-man learns how to be a
cool-ass guy living up to his potential
as well as the friendly neighborhood
hero that we know that's a movie baby
that's a movie
all right that's a movie baby
what mark in what do you have to say
about it okay well I went with silk
Cindy moon okay so those that are not
familiar with her she was bitten by the
same radioactive spider that
that peter parker her skill set includes
a more enhanced spidey sensor she calls
it a silk sense it's more long-range
that's stronger than Peters she's faster
than Peter and she's able to spend from
her fingertips and she can spend
different kinds of webs she can do a
electric absorbing she need to shock
absorbing it's she's pretty she's pretty
awesome in that way um the thing that
makes it a really great idea to have her
be an animated feature you don't have to
do a lot of heavy lifting with her there
aren't a whole lot of things that you'd
have to shear off or r2r to get rid of
she she had her powers her powers like
freaked out her freaked out her parents
her parents had her go to Ezekiel Simms
who kind of locked her in a vault for 10
years
but Peter gets her out she's back out
into the world it goes
part and parcel with the spider first
thing it happens on after she's released
from the vault and she is she's she's
free and she's free in New York and she
becomes silk and one of the great things
about her I think of what I really like
for her for animated feature it's
because she was locked up for you know
like those 10 years she's she's like a
fish out of water she's she's awkward in
the world but she's awkward in the world
that's familiar like you remember Peter
being awkward in the world like that but
it's in a different way and it's in a
way that different kinds of fans can
connect with like people that are older
in her life what's this Twitter thing
she doesn't know what's order his you
know she ends up working at the fact
channel which is run by a JJ Jonah
JJ Jonah Jay to the third power jonah
Jameson and he likes her he calls her
analog because she's running around with
you know paper and pen she doesn't know
better so it's like um but with her
adventures like her first adventure she
takes down a very malicious black cat
and super hyper powered electro and it's
it's and she has this adorable and very
hot attraction to Peter Parker like both
of them says they were bitten by the
same spider so there's so much to play
with
and it's I don't know it just sets it up
for a new generation oh and she's a
Korean American cuz you know let's do
more let's do better right on yeah so
thank you mark here
Silke coy I would like to do a character
that would expand the world in a very
different direction I went with a
character that isn't a Parker isn't tied
to a Parker but is tied to spider-man
mythos and that is of course spider
woman who was integral to the spider
verse world and the reason I like Spider
Woman is this is a character who was a
spy so you could play at the animation
aspect I'd love to see a pulp noir I'd
love to see like an old Pulp style like
when you read look how your brain
visualized that but in animation because
we saw with spider-verse this style of
animation how they can make anything
work and I kept wanting more spider-man
noir
I'd like a Spider Man noir that was
Spider Woman but you could play with the
spy angle I want to see a movie that is
a detective mystery I miss detective
stories and I think animation can really
have that medium access that also she
was an agent of shield you can tie in
shield you can tie in intrigue also
she's a mom and moms especially single
moms do not get enough love in the
animation world there's everyone has
like the single dad mythos everyone has
the family I want to see Incredibles
where it's the mom taking care of a kid
she's a superhero that has to get home
to her mother there's a babysitter
there's so many things that the comic
was able to deal with that I feel like a
single mom taking their kid to a movie
when they go see a superhero be like
yeah fine let's go see Aquaman let's go
see spiders but if it's a single mom
taking care of a kid that's a superhero
moms are superheroes and this is the
first time they've really made that into
a character add that the spy intrigue
add that the mystery add that the fact
that she's a spider person it builds you
a spider verse laterally so you're not
just going down one path Reverend as the
same powers you're expanding the world
into a new world and that's how you
build a spider verse is by expansion in
all directions
all right fight it out you guys well
speaking of expansion in all directions
how about expansion in the original
direction because one of the ways I want
there to be all the spider people Myles
Gwen that they say that the next movie
is going to be that all female a Spider
Man spider spider person team they're
going to do that but one thing Sony
needs to do to make sure this IP stays
alive and they can keep making some
scrilla off of it let's keep the young
boy Peter Parker involved you know how
you do that
you do this damn along with all these
movies you do the Peter Parker of the
movie where he gets to be Peter Parker
gets to be the spider-man so you can
keep the damn I've won this argument
anymore I'm tired of waiting I'm not
gonna I'm tired of waiting for us to
have our female lead this was gonna come
out animate this one's good this one I'm
positive would come out after yours
Jessica true and sunk and all them is
probably gonna be in the very next
fighter first movie and spider Quinn
who's cooler than both of your guys
characters I don't know what you're
doing question is excluding any
character already yeah we would have all
chose the spider boy station yes this
was being based off of who was presented
in the marketing for into the spider
verse the characters that they listed
this is coming out I think the day
before the movie comes out I certainly
haven't seen it so any of these
characters that haven't already been
announced or if they're in the movie we
just don't know about it it's still fair
game
thank you I'm telling guys there's a
character that's in an amazing tech suit
that's a billionaire that's a scientist
you may have heard of me as Iron Man
superior spider-man's a lame Iron Man I
don't need to see more of that we
already have entitled billionaire
characters yes this is the character
that let's have a character that gets
more entitled let's have a character
that wins by being a bully let's have a
character that says horrible things
let's have a character that's mean to
inspire children I don't want my kids
seeing superior spider-man as a hero I
don't want someone to achieve by being a
villain that hater wins in me and that's
disingenuous we don't need it as an
animated feature not at this point where
we are in our history fighter man and
also Jessica drew is just both of these
characters that's a lot of you guys
chose characters that it's gonna be a
lot of heavy lifting to be able to like
make it happen
well you you're gonna have to lay it
like a lot of brown work to be able to
then be like oh oh here yeah I hear a
speeder and then here's OH
switch brains Oh Otto has cancer oh no
he switched he switched brains with
Peter and then and then like Jessica
it's like oh now we have to tell in an
animated feature about Hydra I know we
have to do about sword and shield and oh
now we have to make it a single mom
that's a lot of stuff and I think for
the first animated feature I mean just
talking about like the the global view
of where people are like super fans like
us and then people that are budding fans
it's like the next step should be
something that makes progressional sense
where you just have silk you have Cindy
where it's it's very simple and then
like she also has tragic backstory she
can't find her family
very similar characters well we can't do
any into this just like a character
she's she's not like spider-gwen at all
they're totally different because she's
way super mothering great story actually
orange I beat the jump for inclusion as
well but unbreakable kimmy silk sucks
I'm sorry Joe I made a done it it's like
we're gonna do a big montage of her
being trapped in a bunker watch The
Breakfast Club over and over again
building my brain switching machine one
of these suits parents and one of these
tells a morality story only one of these
is a good message for kids and that is
the one where it's saying a single mom
is the hero and she has lost her family
she is trying to find her family she's
trying to find her way in the world and
not only that with this with her
storyline there is so much beautiful
diversity and inclusion you have
same-sex relationships and trying to
find your way there it's like she is
fighting her way through the world and
you're on that journey along with her
you can make spider-woman Korean in my
movie without it being the whole plot
like you're just adding inclusion as the
whole that's all right let's put it on
pause and actually shift gears final
thoughts at Greer start us off I look
look
I said it before
I just don't this bunker person I will
stop it I just don't I don't get that
they could have made her so much cooler
in so many different ways but this is
where the character we have I'm a bunker
lady and I got out of the bunker and now
oh I use pencils how archaic look get
out of here and and and coins character
I love Jessica drew I think she's super
fresh but doing a bunch of spy stuff
with a baby on your yarn while you're
flipping pass bullets and stuff is
irresponsible something as I stated in
the world that I think we're living in
this movie would come out after the one
with all the spite of women who are
interesting and it would come out you
know I mean so both you guys wouldn't be
absorbed into one movie and in my movies
that keeps the IP of Peter Parker alive
would come out and save the day with a
really cool story that is not about a
bully it's about how once potential can
be monstrous maybe living all the way up
to your potential isn't super great if
it's gonna make you a bully maybe it's
better if you embrace who you actually
are and what you actually want to do
rather than what other people think you
should do ie owning a company and
running the city with spider drones
Peter Parker learns that that's not the
right way and becomes a hero
it takes Becca's mantle at the ad that's
beautiful Thank You Anne mark yeah final
thoughts so for this first animated
feature with silk she has a photogenic
memory so like it's done in the comic
book you would simply have it where you
have flashback sequences as she's
progressing in her life so you're going
on this superhero journey with her just
like you did back when it was with Peter
Parker so I'm you you get to meet Albert
her her younger brother like in
flashback while she's at work while
she's swinging while she's fighting
dragon claw you know you you while she's
um being antagonized and is going after
black cat it's like this is part and
parcel with like this this this IP for
her it's and it's it's so it's so great
because it hits that point where it's
like yes this can be for kids but it's
so for us to which is what most of these
animated features are it's like silk is
in that beautiful area where it can
literally be for anybody and it I'm like
I said before totally tired of having to
like wait to have like a like this kind
of person and I also like that it's not
a spider something she's silk she's
different so thank you Marquis a coin so
my thing with with these characters is
the the story it tells needs to be for
all ages which I agree with what you're
saying I just feel like with silk
stories you can plug-and-play spidered
women a lot of them and I feel I can
superior spider-man you can
plug-and-play Iron Man a lot of them
only one of these characters is unique
to themselves only one of these
characters has lasted since the 70s only
one of these characters is the only one
that you can tell this story for and
that is a mom superhero that is a spy
and that is the only movie that like
you'll have different styles of
animation you'll have different stories
to tell you have more world building
that isn't following just the spider-man
path you're expanding and it tells a
story that would be approachable to so
many different types of people that
these other stories might not approach
and I really think that it's an untapped
market do not have Jessica drew because
they literally gave Brian Michael Bendis
Jessica Jones because they wouldn't let
him write jessica droops they didn't
trust that property going forward I
think Jessica drew story needs to be
told because it hasn't yet and the way
they've expanded her is so inventive and
creative in ways that I don't think
these characters are and I don't want
the slight bad influence or the the
slight de railing of these characters
where his mind can't be she's a single
mom that's a spy that's just it's
awesome Anakin I can see it animated
time there we go boom Billy biz yet so
far as I can find I see no evidence that
Jessica drew brings her baby into battle
there are lots of pictures please give
us your thoughts yes so look all three
of these were great usually I I can
eliminate one and focus on two but this
time I felt like all three of these were
we're really great choices so for me I
had to take into consideration the
semantics of the question which was
which spider-verse character should have
their own animated feature and for me I
felt like both Edie and Marcia pitched
incredible spider-verse sequels whereas
koi for me pitched something that was in
the spider world but was it's complete
own thing complete different look
complete different take on a character
that we don't really know so well so for
me I'm going with koi it's one for koi
yeah these were all good arguments I
really thought marki I made some great
points about inclusion and just want to
see the different character and she sold
that story which Edie really hated the
fact that silk was imprisoned in a
bunker free like EDD is very anti bunker
man I think koi I I think it was koi
that level dead with just a lame Ironman
comment I thought that was like a
devastating blow yes the superior
spider-man and at the end of the day I
agreed with Billy I thought koi painted
a picture of a world that was different
yet still spider-verse and got me them
just the most excited by those different
elements so yeah I go Khoikhoi you take
this point Danielle any other thoughts
on this one I was just like boom boom
boom just like picking him up and
knocking him down yeah but yeah I want
to see all of them I can't wait right on
okay so it is one for koi one forum
archaea Edie looking to get on the board
question number three here we go what
movie character from any any movie
should be the MCU slash Tom Holland
spider-man's next villain any movie
villain wow this is kind of like a dream
matchup so unlock unlock the dream vault
and give it to us and let's start with
mark eeeh uh yeah so because we don't
know that much about her teenage life
because it's just you know you don't
really know about that you know that she
becomes like an intergalactic and
intergalactic she becomes a global
assassin yes I want a teenage Oren Ishii
from Kill Bill to be the MCU Tom
Hollands next villain and I think it
would fit so well you have this transfer
student quiet doesn't do friends kind of
a thing maybe even pretends that she
only speaks Japanese and let's say Peter
knows a love a Japanese so it's like oh
she can't avoid him he's gonna be nice
to the new student while she's really
there to be undercover trying to get at
her next target maybe it's her also
interning at alchemax or something like
that but it's like what it would be
though is that I would want Peter to get
close to orin orin to see that okay
maybe there is a different side to thing
and then to go through with her
assignment anyway I want to see the both
of them him a Spider Man her in her
decked out where that you see in the in
the anime cut sequence that you see in
Kill Bill when you're learning about the
progression of Oh Ren I want to see her
doing that through the streets of New
York City going after targets spider-man
going after her then battling him
stopping her that time and then her
realizing who he is later on in the
movie and maybe even killing her target
in front of him where it's like she
doesn't do friends she doesn't do
closeness she has a destiny and I kind
of want to like have that because in my
head then like later when she's fighting
you know her own personal demons like
her own history coming back I kind of
want Peters to be like the last name in
her head before it goes flying off her
shoulders all right oh you just give a
spoiler teenage or any she excellent
teenage Oren Ishii from Kill Bill series
boy Randy oh so I went with the
character I also I went through looking
through like major villains and I went
through looking at major spider-man
villains and there's so few female
villains and and that like was it
surprised me because I thought I'd find
a more two parallel and then I realized
there's only one female villain that
suits the age bracket that I love and
she is the character we all grew up
hating she is the character that
bothered us from the moment we opened
that book and that is Professor Dolores
Umbridge I would like to see a poor poor
Tom Hollands spider-man stuck in
detention having to deal with this woman
undermining his sense of responsibility
making him doubt himself the thing that
runs spider-man is his sense of
self-worth his whole great power and
great responsibility is his through line
his moral compasses there so if you have
a professor like Professor Dolores
Umbridge making you think less of
yourself demoralizing you that will
affect you in battle so I love the idea
that I love when these movies really a
multi-prong villain attack we've never
had a multi-prong villain attack that is
both him being assaulted by a professor
and him being assaulted on the
battlefield so I like the idea of him on
the battlefield distracted by being worn
down like Harry Potter was by being
demoralized like Umbridge would and
the image I have in my head is basically
with great power comes great
responsibility is always the thing
that's etched into our mind I'd love to
see that Ashton to his hand so you bring
in the Doctor Strange magic into Harry
Potter into this world you bring all
that tied together and with great powers
great responsibilities the poster and
he's writing that over and over again
detention and it's getting an s2 uns
hand like Harry Potter did because she
doesn't believe in Peter Parker's moral
compass which affects him in any battle
so she's the true villain of the movie
all right taking it to the potter verse
head I just can I start my rebuttals
already because I just don't have the
patience for even my opening statement
because I got I gotta say I dye my
character my character it will also be
someone that it battles battle
spider-man but this person you can't
beat them his name is dick Vernon and he
is the vice principal for Shermer high
the school from The Breakfast Club you
mess with the bull you get the horn so
you mess with this guy he don't got a
Sim Sim salabim I whip out a wand
he doesn't have to attack your sense of
self-worth because you're worthless son
you're worthless
and he's one of these guys he heard a
ruckus hey you're fighting the vulture
in there he heard a ruckus and he came
in there to check on it you don't even
mean the next crew that falls out is you
Parker you know I mean that sort of
thing I just would love to see that
because even in homecoming he gets put
in detention and he walks out on on on
Hannibal Burres character because he's
too weak he's too weak he's not hard
like dick Vernon you know I mean so so
this guy he'll he'll keep you in
detention and oh oh you got some
questions Parker that's another week
I'll answer that question next Saturday
Parker you know I mean he's just he's a
guy that you can't defeat by
conventional means much like Adrian
Toomes his he has an old man authority
over Parker that I feel is is greater
than what Umbridge could bring and
frankly let me tell you something this
Umbridge lady homeboy reads
Harry Potter okay he's a millennial
kitty weeds Harry Potter he's ready for
magic ladies he ain't seen no Breakfast
Club he thinks that's an ancient movie
prepare for my man dick Vernon all right
that's it fight it out okay first shot
bang I just felt like a detention I'm
kind of covering but with the magic
doctor straight from her but like I feel
like your character is just like
extremely there's our gutless turds let
me tell you and she and she were in has
any agency at all she's not being a
cliched asian love interest for Peter
for half a movie she's gonna go pursue
her own goals and on her own business
no femme fatale no intrigue she's on her
own missions just had to play around
with spider-man if she has any agency
but if you want to create a character
with no agency that kicks up what this
might do half the movie for no reason
because that was a really good influence
for like you heard romance mr. executive
i'ma throw that romance in there you
know well now she she mood has MJ and
all that possibility no I want like
she'd be a perfect foil for Peter
because she cannot be saved her her path
is set but he is still gonna try because
he's Peter Parker as soon as he figures
out who it is that she is but what the
both of you well the both of your
character is Dolores on want for
one already saw it in Harry Potter I
don't need to see it
I don't eat that detention scene of him
writing something in his hand because I
you know I already saw that researcher
sound the same in with a vice principal
Richard Vernon it's like we're talking
about who's the villain these are these
are like fun like backdrops this is like
the back web of that spinning you know
poor for the rest wasn't even we're
talking about incontrovertible powers
though okay at least my character could
keep me in detention he can't just walk
out on dick Brennan he's gonna get his
permanent record messed up do you know
what Aunt May is gonna do to Peter if
his permanent record is messed up by my
man dick Vernon and homegirl can do that
plus magic you have an assassin who's
taking on a guy who throws Volkswagens
routinely I will web her up and toss her
out the damn window
that's the river
playing in the hand belong and daredevil
for a reason and you just like a lecture
can be that rollin Marvel would use
their own character instead I don't need
an assassin movie and you just described
her as being like a with Peter and
against Peter so it's not really the
villains she and you have that dichotomy
of her like is this gonna be a friend
type of thing will Peter be able to
change yours like no like Alec's a baby
because you gave us detention people
because I want to use psychological
warfare I want this to be okay whiplash
is a movie about psychological warfare
between teacher and student
I want that plus magic so Dolores
Umbridge I want Peter Parker to not
trust his moral compass the reason Peter
Parker identified we had to invite Peter
Parker is because the moral code of
Peter if he doesn't trust his own moral
compass like Dolores we're doing an a
she did Harry Potter that would be a
carriage that would not be fighting well
so that makes them the true villain you
can have all of your other villains but
a Peter doesn't trust himself then she's
one that makes her the ultimate I'm
saying you can have a villain that can
do it both get yourself a villain that
new info but also Vernon can do it do it
but they can't do it one really good
like undermining you say that umbrage
can undermine Peters confidence when
Peter gets told something like you
should spend more time working on
yourself and less time trying to impress
people that would really hit home with
with Peter Parker that's a direct quote
from dick Burton love the deep burning
let's go to our final thoughts starting
with mark yeah okay so yeah because I
really enjoy with what we would have
with a teenage or any she is because you
would have work you're not completely
certain that she's the villain at first
it's like it's it's one of those slow
burns that happens where it's like oh
there's this assassin character oh
there's also this person at school that
Peter is trying to get close to and then
you figure out that they're both the
same and that's just that's gonna be
like a power hit for him and then it's
like who was her target that she's
taking down like this major person and
then along with that I just really enjoy
that you could even incorporate some of
the styles that you had with like Kill
Bill with that with showing the teenage
over an issue like her you know
destroying assassin people like you can
have that and bring that over and to
spider-man I mean I think this will work
out really well and especially because
this isn't just a one note thing this
isn't just focusing on one little area
of um Peter Parker's life which is like
just attention just at school this is
school this is Peter personal and this
is spider-man itself Oh Rin is ultimate
like Swiss Army knife villain or an easy
quick so I believe in a villain that
affects you in all the different ways as
you're describing and I think the only
one that would be actually be able to
keep him in detention probably using
magic would be Dolores Umbridge and I
feel like if Pierre Parker spider sense
is going off and he's aware that he
can't help that'll affect him if he's
sitting in detention and he's trapped by
magic and he knows the city is crumbling
around him that'll affect him and then
on top of that having her literally
verbally affect Peter making him feel
like he doesn't trust himself that'll
affect him and as this movie comes to a
head she could
be the big villain and have a magic
fight because she knows freaking magic
so if you want someone that does all of
the things incorporate the Doctor
Strange mysticism incorporate the world
building and core played a character
that already hates children use the
world because we have a young Tom
Holland don't just waste it on a
character that I love easy as a villain
she shows up on a lot of villain list
for a reason but she doesn't fit this
world because dared of an Electra have
that dynamic already and it's a
beautiful dynamic and she also like I
don't see how the confidant versus
villain angle is different than any
other movie we've seen plus I mean I
love I love the character Vernon but
he's literally a guy's spider-man can
swing out the window or he can literally
just want you leave spider-sense goes
off he leaves like he didn't Hannibal
Buress Hannibal Buress played that role
very well and I enjoyed the comedic
stylings of the movie we just had I want
that to be a teacher that can I want to
have our cake and eat it too and use the
high school element in all the different
ways all right and guys I feel like when
I pick a joke answer I get penalized
because people start to get super
logical and then when I pick a logical
answer people go oh no well you got to
check the best joke so let me try to hit
both of those number one or an ECE would
get slung out the window I'm a Weber up
and throw her out the window ninjas for
breakfast by this time it's probably
1820 months in the future he's got a lot
of experience doing stuff you're good
did I throw you out the window
now Laura umbrage i if I'm spider-man
I read Harry Potter I'm a I'm a bust up
your core crux am I saying that right
guys I don't know in the end in the end
the stuff that I in the stuff that I did
research that was a major thing or the
Horcrux got messed up and the blahblah
and if you read the stories he knows
that her mom was a muggle who took our
brother away he can attack her
psychologically and and he looks at
bullets when they go by you think you
can't whip up your mouth right before
you waiting for sweet wave your wand or
do your dumb spell get out of here
this kid is fast the kid is fast read
the comics
your mouth is webbed up you thrown out
the damn window Delores so I can throw
this ninja brought out the damn window I
can throw this other lady out the damn
window but you know what I can't do Oh
Richard t-bird
just say look man I'm a man of respect I
make $31,000 a year you take these damn
webs off me son and you sit back down at
your chair you know what he'd do he
would do that each citizen share so damn
it Richard T Vernon runs that school he
ain't gonna hear no stuff from
spider-man
oh why you got a detention I'll try not
for a scholarship get your ass back in
that room and sit down Peter Richard
Dean Vernon is a villain who can do both
which both of those things just keep you
in detention thank you Sam okay that is
time Billy biz where we go I'll get to
the gym I mean that I just that was
actually you nailed those quotes
Danielle please favor us with your
thoughts on this round oh gosh okay
there so I'm dead I this is hard because
this is one of those ones where I think
I'm gonna I think I'm gonna be the odd
man out on this I as much as I do think
that or one ish we would be amazing in
it but there was the point that it is
very much it's very close that Elektra
and daredevil so it does wind up being
close to that relationship so that kind
of knocked that out as interesting as
that would be as much as I I hate to say
swung out the window again but he brings
up a good point that like Dolores as a
villain would be punchable spider-man's
not gonna hit some dude make him 31 ka
years
he's not gonna hit he's not gonna get
Vernon I have to go into converted all
right human man that's one for vice
principal dick Vernon
Millie yeah this one was strange I feel
like and your commitment to the bit is
just that's how Rudnick worthy committed
to the bed but this was to down to coy
and Marcia for me
coy you just painted such a great
picture I mean like your movie poster
stuck with me the entire time I really
loved that you know I could see the
marketing but I feel like every time you
were trying to knock down Marcius your
punches were actually just strengthened
her arguments like it's like the hand
it's like yeah that makes her just make
a little bit more sense actually I feel
like I saw clearly what the story was
with over and Ishi
and it also makes Onishi kind of a
cooler character and killed bill later
if you have kind of this other piece of
knowledge about her in this other world
I kind of just like that whole pitch
better something on Marcia all right so
it's one for add one from archaea comes
down over here you know I think mark Kia
really laid out my thoughts on this
matchup
pretty succinctly when she said these
characters feel like the part of the
backdrop of this spider story and just
as far as the villain that would that
we'd focus on and has the most
compelling action for me it's also mark
'ya with Oren Ishii so I'm going mark
iam Archaea you get the points and that
puts Marky and coy into the speed round
Edie thank you so much to come in here
I'm cracking skulls
time for the speed round Marcia and coy
Marky is up two to one and first person
to four here is question one of the
speed run y'all ready ready let's go
excluding all spider-man and spider
Rider
the best movie spider excluding all
spider-man related stuff Charlotte's Web
Charlotte's Web it it all right coy when
you begin you have twenty seconds you'll
have a twenty second rebuttal mark eeeh
and then twenty seconds after that and
then you'll eat you get a ten second
rebuttal
kawaii whenever you're ready I got to
talk about a spider that not only is the
through line in the heart of this movie
but she's also a spider that teaches you
a moral compass that makes you feel that
makes you a mote that makes you see the
world differently this is of course
these Charlie the web spider who when
she dies you feel more first biter than
you ever have she transcends the species
of spider she makes you understand that
everything the animal is worth a life
everyone has the right to live and
through this death you look at spiders
so as so as soon as you begin speaking
twenty seconds yep it's your turn
so you've yeah for Oh easy way you could
talk about his or yours and his either
way okay
twenty seconds begin when you speak now
the spider from it is the best movie
spider because it's something that you
do not see coming up to that point with
it you just have like this scary clown
that it turns out that it's from outer
space and once you actually get into its
lair and it's it strikes that probably
more like that primal fear within you
where it's like no you thought the
clowns are bad enough now you have this
ridiculous huge space spider to also
deal with I agree spiders are scary but
I also like spiders that teach you thank
you every spiders life matters spiders
lives matter too and I think that the
only movie that shows you that every
living creature has a purpose if
Charlotte's Web when she dies you feel
it and she teaches me about a person
every living creature has a purpose is
to feed the it spider show but what's
Charlotte's Web it's just like you know
that school this is a spider that you
know spend stuff but this is a spider
from spaceship that marking a district
yeah
Khoi spoke to me with with charlotte
memorial compass and yeah every living
thing has value so I go koi Billy what I
don't condone spider lives matter
I've never seen maybe might Stretch
Armstrong doll when I was a kid anything
stretched the way that koi could stretch
out the moral compass Charlotte but it
was at least just a hair more than I got
then these spiders are really scary so I
call right but good god man yeah yeah
yeah good good call let's not coop
very sincere okay
so coy has tied us up despite any
missteps there okay there's a lot
bouncing it's tricky question two of the
speed round we're tied up to two who
should play Jay jonah Jameson and the
MCU Tom Holland Spidey movies Nick
Offerman waiting army Eddie circus Andy
Serkis all right Nick Offerman Andy
Serkis
COI 20 seconds begin when you speak the
beautiful thing about jenna jameson is
the duality of the character and no one
does like that Ron Swanson himself Nick
Offerman he is both brittle he is harsh
but he's also a heart of gold you care
about his actual choices while you hate
the fact they eat the spider-man minutes
you can see him here Diaz the mustache
you can hear the morale of his voice
everything that Nick Carr from in suits
jonah jameson and everything that the
part of the dad that jonah is to his son
is also Nick Hoffman the duality of the
character is very hard to get he would
get it right Andy Serkis is a fantastic
actor that can do the balance that I
Jenna Jameson wouldn't need where it's
like he's kind of a caricature of a
person but he makes him real grounded
gritty and you can totally picture him
in this particular role it's something
that he hasn't done to date and I think
that's something that would interest him
to be and part of Marvel in this way and
he'd look completely different than my
favorite I agree he would do all those
things but I feel like Nick Carr for
making land the better and I also think
that this character is made for him it's
shaped for him as entire sonography has
led to this everything character is and
the box office trying to government come
into this role would be everything we
want to see plus just a visual give me
visual spider-man I think Nick Offerman
probably too busy like building
furniture at the time and it's just this
one Andy Serkis makes a better pick for
jonah Jameson just because of how he is
as an actor and what he portrays on
screen
alright Daniel Radford um for these I
why do I think both choices are really
really interesting I was really hoping
that you would that marki would hit on
the fact that maybe it's too similar to
what - Ron Swanson because I was waiting
for that because I totally would have
knocked him out but I didn't I didn't
get that I didn't get it strong enough
for but on that from either so the one
that wound up being more compelling is
boy Billy yeah I think boy you let you
let your guard down but Marc eeeh
you failed to knock him out there were a
couple points that you could have hit
that could have easily taken down just
didn't get to him so I'll go for quick
alright coy you take that point you're
up three two vaults into the lead in the
speed around anybody's game
but it is game point it's three two coy
mark eeeh you need this to keep her
going
alright here we go question three of the
speed round worst spider-man villain
performance Jamie Foxx's electro or
Topher Grace's venom Topher Grace okay
we have Marc Kia with Grace's venom and
coy you have Jamie Foxx's electro mark
you you spoke first so uh 20 seconds
begin when you speak now
I was legit upset with Topher Grace's
venom he should have never been venom he
that he's not venom at all like
everything that his Topher Grace does
not lend a venom he's not a bully he
would not have been chosen by the
symbiote by any way shape or form and
then that actual performance in that
movie is just and plus way too many
villains for that particular movie did
not have to shoot Lauren finiman there
Topher Grace event was based off the
ultimate spider-man it's actually very
similar I could see what he was trying
to do he was more of a peer you're
supposed to see the Topher Grace versus
to inquire duality and there was the
similarities there so I see what they
were trying for words electro is not
based off any comic property this was
founded in no rational thought and the
way that it landed was actually more
cartoonish some up in the Sam Raimi won
least Topher Grace was playing the Sam
Raimi styled this style was not found in
any reality amazing spider-man didn't
land a format what Jamie Foxx's
performance says Elektra he was max I
mean max was a pitiful character and he
was able to do that in a can
fencing way unlike what Topher Grace
where he actually had a really cool
character that he could have done
something with and he just fell
completely faceplant
what venom represents is the darkness of
spider-man so it makes sense to have
Topher and Toby who are very similar
what electro represents is a low-low
character that gets too much power jamie
foxx didn't land any of that so it
actually didn't strew to the heart of
the character at least he was Olsen
spider-man time Wow you know what even
though I in in real IRL I agree with coy
argument wise just what I heard right
here I got a I got a go with Mark eeeh
on this one Billy I'm a hundred percent
with you
you had me when he said I don't think
the symbiote would have chosen Topher
Grace mark eeeh you just tied up this
ballgame and we are going to game point
although yeah man just that Jamie Foxx
it felt like sketch comedy yeah like
that performance and that move even
though I loved him and so many other
movies okay this is for the ball game
what canceled netflix defender character
should do a one-off team-up film with
spider-man we heard and boy first with
daredevil cancelled Netflix defender
character calling wink
calling wing all right boy whenever
you're ready
daredevil beautifully reflects darkness
spider-man beautifully reflects light to
the dichotomy of the characters will
make them work because though they're
physically similar they both swing
around they're both red suits the way
they have Tom Hollands character versus
the darkness of Charlie Carson's
daredevil would be a really beautiful
movie because of the duality of these
characters both of them represent good
but they're represented in a different
way so I would be very compelled to see
that way because you can see what
different heroes are and how they'd be
and they're both in New York so it
really fits into the universe plus the
team-up I want to see a Spider Man and
calling winged because it would be a
different side of spider-man it'd be
like even more ground-level
going with things with like daughters of
the Dragon you know busting up you know
underground rings and the such like that
it's like not so much spider-man flying
through the air so much as being
street-level which which is what the
defenders are they're the ones they're
the boots on the ground so having that
with calling winged that would then
bring in everybody else with daughters
ring it'd be as simple if having spatter
may need a lawyer and therefore Matt
Murdock that's bound to happen and it
all ties in beautifully she'd have the
low level in the Quarian of the high
level with the swinging plus that's the
movie ever want to see another movie
like budget so I want to go not to
finish I don't to go movie I don't to go
spider-man that suits the team-up plus
the duality these things would make it
interesting and along with them going
with calling wing I think that that
would open up a whole new audience for
people also because it's like it's
you're getting to see that different
kind of spider-man and it shows you a
whole new part of New York something
with spider-man you usually just have no
rooftops to be on the ground alright
Danielle Oh so as much as I love the
idea of have him with with a daredevil
because they're so physically similar
you can see the way that people fight
crime differently I love her really
stressing that like different kind of
spider-man boots on the ground something
that you haven't really gotten to see a
whole lot of in the movies and so
because of that I can we go with murky
yet yeah these are both great arguments
and different movies but yeah I thought
koi sold me on just how these two fit
together and just the kind of a battle
way and in like two
this spiritual dark meets light so yeah
I'm going Chloe with daredevil all comes
down to Billy biz the comments will tell
me I'm wrong either way but I have to go
with the one that I felt stood out to me
a little bit more I felt like daredevil
was a perfect choice and you said
everything that you should say should
you choose daredevil but Colleen wing is
one that came out of left field and it
made sense when she said it and how she
set it up so I'm going marki you on this
one mark yeah you are today's movie
fights when you swung into the
spider-verse and you emerged a champion
nicely done please give a spot shout
outs etcetera oh like where you can find
me on social media just like this in
general whatever you want and social
media so much adrenaline going on right
now I don't know how it looks but like
inside I'm like oh yeah great win great
win oh thank you Wow um yeah I do not
like speed routes um yeah I guess if you
know converse on social media I'm on a
Twitter and Instagram at marki McCarty
and then a if you have DC Universe
platform you know DC Daily
I mean cardigan fool you do that and I
also a fangirling if you're not so into
you know comics like deep down like
super fans like this I mean we do
pop-culture topics and everything we do
that on every Thursday in fact um and I
think we've had a number of people in
the building that have come through
there for like fangirling so yeah and
you can do that on Facebook facebook.com
slash watch man girly I guess thank you
and yeah this man took it to the edge
three three pulled it out nicely done ed
Grier always great to have you in here
and we're always anxious to see what if
you don't make it to the speedrun which
is rare what art will you create
a Jew at Donatello yeah dude I tell
nicely done and tell us where we can
find you well I'm the president of the
dick Vernon fan club you can find me get
we only accept faxes now but I have a
podcast called a nerd goat podcast a
nerd as a nerd greatest of all time it's
a deep dive into people's favorite
fictional characters and I'd like to
officially invite you guys to be on like
that's that's kind of coordinated after
this but uh yeah it's it's it's it's a
pretty great show
we're rising we're five-star rated
podcast our patreon is doing well and
herbed goat podcast Forks last patreon
whatever how you do it and uh and I am
on screen junkies every Wednesday and
last Wednesday there was a rating spike
I wonder why so yeah I'm going for my
Cougar I'm not trying to win anymore
it's just all jokes
oh yeah and yeah just check now and
Grier destroys on all social media and
please check out my Instagram where I do
better drawings than that Donatello if
you went on nerd goat like if you were
interviewing yourself on nerd goat you
would be interviewing yourself about
dick Vernon correct oh yeah yeah
or daredevil that man always great to
have yet cold you took it to the limit
who like that's me on it's always fun
really do it's all I can actually speak
as fast as my brain goes I get car
commercial meats like mattress like
James may include spider-man yeah Micro
Machines I just loved it so my first
choices were Tom on Mikey Alfred Molina
second one was Jessica drew made a
Parker spear spider-man and silk third
choice was Dolores ember Georgina Gorge
whiplash and bill the butcher so I loved
it like so much of this we all the same
ideas so I was really fun fighting
things that I was like wait no I agree
with you right that made this battle
really intense and like that was insane
so that wasn't that was a great fight I
had so much fun you can find me Collider
heroes every Wednesday you can find me
popping up an artist you can find me
here whenever they let me get into speed
around and I just I love this so much
and screen junkies fans are great so
thank you guys for cheering me on and
the not live version of this in the
future oh and we did the into the
spider-verse special we did a special
for Wednesday club geek and sundry at
geekus entry so you can catch that I
think it's out there yeah so yeah we
talk all things spider-verse we had not
seen the movie by then so yeah talk
everything right oh yeah sounds like a
deep dive and these three right here
always great to have each and every one
of you bring it and you have vast troves
of knowledge thank you for being here
Billy biz what up had a blast today
sitting in the band chair let us know in
the comments who you would want a web up
and swing out a window our choices oh
yeah Daniel Radford you guys can find me
here on Thursdays you can also check out
my my wrestling podcast I do have a
patron we're doing more movie content
now I think two of my favorite movies
The Last Dragon and that other one that
I love a bunch of my favorite movies are
on Netflix so we're gonna be doing some
live chat along sweat so keep them in a
cup of coffee and you can come in and
hang out with this oh heck yeah I'm
Danielle I'd imagine you'd be just so
much fun to hang out and watch movies
with and just talk to it about the
movies yes that's exactly what we do
that's awesome
and if yeah I always love just talking
so follow
Instagram and Twitter at Hal Rudnick
yeah we'll talk and we'll talk
elastic owl nation cuckoo
we're Micah hooligans at I want to thank
everybody for watching screen Tony's I
want to thank Billy bits for also
producing I want to thank JT e in the
booth and yeah have fun out there see
you next week bye bye
[Music]
you